what shove teeth three bit cheeky nugget
[Music]
hello everybody my name is chef Tiana G
I am a sous chef and I also have a
cooking channel on YouTube called
cooking with teeth the thing about two
filets they don't wait on anybody so you
got to get it while it's hot today I am
gonna be trying the best delivery you
can get at your hole without going
outside into the world I'm gonna be a
taster of chicken nuggets so we have
four different nuggets today and then
we're gonna be trying so the first one
chick-fil-a they came with a chick-fil-a
sauce and it came with a barbecue sauce
you there's nothing wrong with you look
at this little piece of chicken you can
tell that it's a piece of chicken if I
open up into it like that you can see
it's not like broken down or ground to
much which is great I really like that
about chicken nuggets oh good if
actually really well-seasoned good bread
to chicken race you own this and I
definitely dig the chick-fil-a sauce
with this I think chick-fil-a is perfect
for somebody who just wants like a
really quick little chicken nugget bite
if you like to eat it in the car maybe
like you're a busy person and you just
want to go grab some quick chicken
nuggets I think this is great for that
Wendy's this is my first time eating
chicken nuggets from Wendy's I really
like the way that is in like a french
fry condensator
breading looks like there's a lot of
pepper in here which was cool I love
pepper I'm gonna take a bite now I like
in taste this barbecue sauce
I only taste the Nugget I'm gonna try it
without the barbecue sauce now though
because that's all I got when I had it
maybe that's what they want them maybe
they just want you to try the Barbie
doll
all right like it looks like the
seasoning but it doesn't really come
through it doesn't leave me it's not
really giving me the pepper that it
looks like there is a lot of death right
here but I'm not really getting that
when I take a bite into it McDonald's
tbh sweet and sour sauce for Mickey D's
is all gasp no breeze taking me back to
a place I played McDonald's is good for
Datak it's good for taking you back to a
place that you want to go back to yeah I
don't know the breading is definitely
interesting definitely really fried
though because it's a bunch of oil in
these Nuggets the breading is what makes
come back for another bite on those apps
a Burger King is also making chicken
nugget I see lots of seasoning on this
nugget
and these nuggets are freaking me out
and the chickens were just like ground
up and like mashed look and they gave me
a honey mustard sauce so I'm assuming
they want me to eat honey mustard with
their nuggets I really I think it's
because it reminds me of their chicken
price there's a lot of seasoning inside
the Burger King nugget actually which is
really cool all right everybody what it
shove cheese grievant chicken nuggets
out before no good that we tried here
today I'm gonna have to say
chick-fil-a I feel like when I'm taking
the bite out of it I get like this nice
juicy texture and I like that for the
breading is not really really too much I
like the seasoning for sure oh this was
my favorite now if you guys want to
watch me more things or whatever you
guys want me to try next comment it down
below because I would love to be your
food yeah
[Music]